I love like the 30s gangster films James
Cagney g-men this movie felt very
inspired by those kind of films with
that absolutely that was the idea as a
kind of an homage to those great
Warner's 30s gangsters movies and why do
you think we love watching gangster
films I think there's something about
gangster movies that's uniquely American
you know it's about ambition it's about
clawing your way ahead it's about
competition it's about testing moral
fabric and seeing how far you can push
things and you know and it's about
ultimately pulling yourself up by your
bootstraps I think it was a period in
history where the government was a
little bit too strong on denying people
what they wanted and so this was a
period where you had you know what the
rise of the gangster the Bonnie and
Clyde's and I know at that time it got
to a point where the country was
cheering these these folks on it's like
a romantic time in a way but there's
also heart to it you think about some of
the 20s and the parties and the fun and
this and the glamour but then there's
also this kind of like roughness to it I
think that's something in the
recklessness of that era of the danger
and the the real I mean people were
living by night I think through a
belying of the first world war and women
in Mansa facing themselves to some
degree chopping the hair off and taking
off their corsets yeah skirts were short
and they were dancing and speakeasies
it's just glamorous and dark and and
totally totally new I love your
character cause she she is strong she
seems to have a good sense of herself
but very compassionate as well what was
your favorite part about her oh just her
strength
you know I viewed her at first in a very
superficial fashion like oh my god like
she's so cheesy
because I I still have yet to conquer
what my definition of a real woman is
you know and then it's not just holding
a gun and and fighting and proving
yourself to men it's it's sometimes
surrendering to who you really are and
and and what you've been through and
what you want your life to be do you
ever feel cool when you play
now they're silver absolutely unless you
can't get the car into the right here
with the costume I you look so cool yeah
we're all going to hell
[Music]
you